안녕하세요 시루입니다 저는 가을겨울에
특히 레이어링을 많이 합니다 제가
레이어링을 하는 그러니까 껴입는 데는
몇 가지 이유가 있는데요 첫 번째로
일단 따뜻합니다 니트 같은 얇지만
보온성 있는 옷을 몇 겹 입으면
따뜻하고 벗기도
편하더라고요 두 번째로 제품에
밋밋함을 채워 줄 수가 있는데요 예를
들어서 카라가 없는 아웃터 안쪽에
카라가 있는 옷을 입고 카라를 빼주면
나름의 재미를 더할 수가 있습니다
마지막으로 제가 가장 중요하게
생각하는 건데요 손이 안 가서 놀고
있는 옷들을 활용할 수가 있습니다
이전 영상에서 제가 몇 번 입고
나왔던 옷 중에 메레 온도르 드리스의
협업으로 나온 빨간 울셔츠 그리고
꼼대 가래 송에 검정색 라운드넥
가디건 조합이 있어요이 빨간 울
셔츠는 사실 매물 직전까지 갔었습니다
셔츠는 화부로 봤을 때 너무 예뻐서
일단 구매했는데 단독으로 입 자니까
생각보다 자기 주장이 강한 옷이라고
그래서 꽤 오랫동안 쟁여두고
[음악]
매물고둥
니다이 옷 이랑도 입어보고 저 옷
이랑도 입어보고 그러다가 마음에 드는
조합이 생기면 그 옷은 생존하는
것이고 이래도 저래도 제 스타일과 좀
거리가 생겼다면 그때 이제 매물을
합니다 아무튼 이렇게 제가 좀
즐겨하는 레이어링을 오늘 몇 가지
소개해 보려
합니다 일단 가장 무난하고 많이들
하시는 레이어링은 스웨터와 셔츠의
조합입니다 이건 제가 그냥 깔끔하게
입고 싶은 가을겨울에 많이 입는
조합인데요 많은 분들이 니트나 맨투맨
안쪽에 흰색 셔츠를 레이어링 하는데
다른 색 셔츠도 괜찮아요 제가 입은
건 빈티지 샴브레이 셔츠인 저는 긴팔
셔츠도 좋지만 안에 입었을 때 좀
불편해서 반팔 셔츠를 레이어링 하려
합니다이 셔츠는 바깥에 네이비 색의
케이블 니트와 색감이 맞아서 자주
같이 입습니다 좀더 그 깔롱을
부린다면 더 개성이 강한 셔츠를
레이어링해 주면 좋아요 가령 기호에
따라서 니트 소재의 카라라 체크
셔츠라 아니면 와이드 카라라 등으로
포인트를 주면 좋습니다 니트는 제가
한창 케이블 니트에 꽂혔던 2023년
겨울에 구매한 윌리엄 로키라
스코틀랜드 브랜드의 제품입니다 저는
뭐 하나 구매하겠다는 마음을 먹으면
정말 수십 수백개의 제품을 찾아봐요
그렇게 KV 니트를 온오프라인으로
정말 백방으로 찾다가 최종적으로이
제품을 랜덤 워크에 가서 입어보고
구매했습니다이 윌리엄 로키라 브랜드는
1874년 스코틀랜드에서 시작한
역사가 정말 깊은
브랜드입니다 유행에 무관한 정석적인
실루엣의 니트를 만드는 브랜드인데
다양한 니트 제품군이 나오지만
그중에서 저는이 케블 니트가 가장
마음에 들더라고요 이이나 랜덤워크 등
한국에서도 판매하고 있어서 방문해서
입어 보시는 걸
추천드립니다 제가 구매한 것의
제품명은 굴란 케이블 프로버 크루넥이
좀 피한 느낌의 니트입니다 가격도
생각보다 괜찮고 매 시즌 나오는
제품이라서 정핏 a 케이블 니트를
찾는 분들은 좋아하실 거예요 저도
다른 색으로 하나 더 구매할까 고민
중입니다 두번째는 제가 가장 오랫동안
해오고 있는 레이어링 조합 중
하나입니다 바깥에는 오무 그리스의
베이스볼 자켓을 안쪽에는 라프
시몬스와 프레드 페리의 협업으로 나온
대님 초오 자켓을 입었습니다 이걸
시도해 보게 된 건 라프시몬스 프레드
페리 제품이 좀 질렸을 때 쯤이에요이
초어 자켓은 제가 2017년 말쯤
지금은 가로 스킬의 마가찌니 된
프레드 페리 플래그십 스토어에서
구매했습니다
그러니까이 옷은 지금 만 일곱 살인
거죠 구매한지 2 3년쯤 지나서 좀
질렸을 때 이렇게 저렇게 고민하다가이
오무 플리스 자켓과 한몸이 돼서
살아남았습니다 이게 제가 가장
좋아하는 조합 중 하나인 이유는
카라와 아우터의 색상 톤은 좀
비슷한데 재질이 극명하게 다르기
때문입니다 제가 셔츠와 니트를
제외하고 다른 재질의 두 옷을 조합한
건 이 옷이
처음이었어요 물론 단품으로 각각
입어도 괜찮긴 합니다 다만 초어
자켓은 너무 오래 입어서 해져 있고
무플리 제품은 좀 어찌 보면 과잠
같은 느낌이
있어요이 각각의 미세한 단점이 같이
입었을 때 보완이 된다는 장점이
있습니다 무플리 베이스볼 자켓은 제
기역으로
2020년쯤 구매한 것 같아요 세계
강남의 무플리 운좋게 시즌오프 때
구매했습니다 지난 이사 FW 시즌에
다른 색상들로 다시이 자켓이
출시됐는데 몇 주 전에 가니까 아직
매장에 있더라고요 신세계 강남점
직원분들이 정말 정말 친절하시니 한번
가서 편하게 보시는 걸
추천드립니다 그다음은 니트와
바람막이의 조합입니다이 세트도 위에
나온 라프시몬스 프레드 페리와
조합하게 된 이유나 사유가 동일해요
일단 모헤어 니트는 헤리티지 플러스의
2019년 FW 제품으로 약 5년 전
시즌오프 때
구매했습니다이 제품은 당시에 제가
헤리티지 플러스라는 브랜드에 좀 꽂혀
있어서
구매했어요 제가 알기로는 헤리티지
플러스가 원래 챔피언 같은 원단을
만드는 브랜드로 가려 했다고
들었습니다 그래서 편직 직조 가공
생산까지
다 한다고 들어서 그 당시에 굉장히
매력을
느꼈었습니다 현재도 동일하게 하는지는
잘 모르겠어요 아무튼 거기다 당시
꽤나 꽂혀 있던 모헤어 니트 이기에
구매를
했습니다 정말 잘 입던이 헤리티지
플러스의 모헤어 니트가 어느 순간 제
옷장 방출 명단에 올랐어요 그래서
이런 조합으로 침 소수를 하게
됐습니다 안에 입은 바람막이는 의제
인데 운동 가거나 산탈 때도 입지만
색이 무난해서 평소에도 자주 찾게
되는 옷입니다 요즘 유수의 아웃도어
브랜드가 많이 나왔잖아요 국내 브랜드
중에 저는 케일이 가장 눈이
가더라고요 제품들이 기능적으로도
괜찮고 하나 사둘 만한 가격이니
추천드립니다 이건 제가 조합해 본 것
중 특히나 두 옷의 재질이 극명하게
차이가 나서 마음에 듭니다 맨투맨과
바람막이를 레이어링하는 분들도 많이
봤는데 저는 그보다 니트와 조합하는게
개인적으로 더 좋더라고요 이건 다른
레이어링과 다르게 두 제품의 색상이
비슷하진 않지만이 회색과 파란색의
조합이 워낙 잘 어울려서 생각날
때마다 같이 입고합니다
한 가지 단점이 있다면 이렇게 둘이
입었다가 벗을 때 굉장한 정전기가
일어납니다 그래도 그걸 감안할 만한
예쁜 조합이라
생각해요 다음은 봄버 자켓과 데님
자켓의 조합입니다이 조합은 무플리
라프시몬스 프레드 페리의 조합에서
차관에 도전해 봤는데 역시나 두
제품의 색감이 잘 맞아서 자주 손이
가는 레이어입니다
이렇게 소개하면서 보니까 제가 정말
그 카라가 없는 제품들을 가만 놔두지
못하는 거
같아요이 헤드메이너 버켓은 단품으로
도 솔직히 굉장히 예쁩니다 이건 몇
년 전에 컬티즌 파이널스 때 정말
좋은 가격에 구매했어요 제 기억으로는
컬티즘 익스클루시브 색상이었다 거
같습니다 색상도 제가 좋아하는
나무색이 헤드메이너 치고 부담스럽지
않은 적당히 오버한 실루엣 인지라
정말 잘입고
있습니다이 조합을 한 이유는 버
자보다는 대님 자켓
때문이에요이 자크 미스의 데님 자켓은
efw 시즌의 제품입니다 데님의
색상이 마음에 들어서 구매했는데이
사이즈가 너무 피해서 단품으로 입으면
좀 부담스럽더라고요
그래서 어떻게 해야 잘 입을 수
있을까
고심하다가이 헤드 메이너 본보 자켓과
매칭하게
됐습니다 날씨가 좀 추우면 이렇게
같이 입고 덜 추울 때는 자크 미스
데님 재켓 위에다가 안데르센
안데르센의 스키퍼 자켓을 매칭해
입어요 본보 자켓이 스키퍼 자켓이
색상은 데님 자켓과 비슷한데 소재가
다르다 보니까 입었을 때이 각 조합의
매력이
있더라고요 지난 프라다 쇼를 보면
아예 가디건의 셔츠 카라를 붙인
제품도
발매했다고 그 제품도 정말 예쁘고
가격만 좋으면 구매하고 싶은 마음도
있습니다 그렇지만 저는 개인적으로 이
계절의 흐름에 따라 변하는 본인의
취향에 맞춰서 동일 제품이라도 다른
방식으로 레이어링을 해 보는게 좋은
거 같습니다 제 영상 속 조합이
당연하게도 정답은 아니니까요 본인의
기호에 맞춰서 옷장 속 친구들을 좀
조합해 보는 걸 추천드립니다 오늘
제가 준비한 이야기는 여기까지입니다
감사합니다